go into contacts and take a look at
somebody who you're kind of friendly
with maybe it's a parent from your kid's
school maybe it's somebody you used to
work with maybe it's a business meeting
you had and you really hit it off but
you've never followed up because you're
both busy and let's pick five pick five
people today and just tax that are
acquaintances that you intuitively think
might become a friend and text them
how's your summer going hope you're well
let's get together and if you need to
call for pickleball or tennis pick five
people who are acquaintances who you
intuitively feel might be a friend and
say hello right now like don't even
hesitate don't say I'll get to it later
like [__] do it right now